[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm link and I'm
red this year
at the round table of dim lighting is
2023 fresh
and we are going to get started for the
first episode of 2023 by talking about
first impressions
and specifically uh First Impressions
that people mostly you people have had
of us uh and this is really a uh what I
hope will be a way for us to learn some
lessons about how you know we put
ourselves out there over the years in
many different forms and we've been
received in many different ways as you
will see and see if we can learn
anything maybe if we need to make any uh
adjustments or just we're still making
First Impressions information hopefully
information is good
all information is good take it and do
what you will with it well information
exists what you do with it determines if
it was good or not uh yeah you can do
good things with information and you
know what it's I think it's just fun to
think about First Impressions so as
we're talking about hours maybe you want
to think about the first impressions
that you make on people one of my
favorite slogans of any product like I
the one that just really stands out for
me is you never get a second chance to
make a first impression of course I
don't know what product that is and
shoulders right or cells in blue so you
don't know I thought it was big red gum
see it doesn't matter no no no no no no
it's a dandruff shampoo I am 90 sure of
that 90 sure that's a dander sham okay
and it's probably head and shoulders
well Head and Shoulders is like but you
don't have dandruff exactly
and if they also did you never get a
second chance to make a first impression
they did
Head and Shoulders is the best it's the
best product on the planet the best
product on the planet I don't know if it
works but oh I still I use I use
everybody asks me all the time what do
you do to get your hair I use Head and
Shoulders conditioner oh wow not a
sponsor I use Head and Shoulders Supreme
which is their like one that doesn't
have the weird stuff in it and at least
Myers uses it as a face wash oh really
and swears by it on Tick-Tock hey it's
good man
so I like that python zinc I think it's
one of the best
slogans you never get a second chance to
make a first impression I don't know if
they came up that's true I think they
just commandeered it it's true man and
it's it's so powerful and you never know
I mean you can't control what people
think of you so like you know I don't
want to go overboard in this thing but
it's it's nice to know how you're
perceived in my opinion and but it's
really hard to know sometimes when you
have a long-standing relationship with
somebody like we have a mythical beast
and by the way a few employees who wrote
in wrote in who called in and left
voicemails
um it's fun to then we might have to get
Jenna's opinion on this and Jenna too
she's here it's fun to hear what people
you know what did you now that we know
each other really well
what did you think of me the first time
we met I don't you know ask a ask the
ask the people you care about now about
back before they knew that they cared
about you what did they think of you you
know could be fun give me fun I tend to
not like the fact that that is true uh
because I tend to one of the things I
believe about myself is that I
consistently do not make a good first
impression okay
in in what way
um
I just you know
I have it you might say that I don't
come across as warm
yeah I don't I don't when I meet
somebody for the first time I'm in very
much sort of a observational
uh standpoint and I'm not trying to get
them to think anything about me and then
about and then like halfway through the
evening I'm like oh maybe I should have
done something to make this person think
a certain way about me so you were just
assessing your first impression of them
not realizing that your face was just
very concentrating I think a lot of
times when I'm meeting somebody my
thought process is honestly is this
person worth the investment of of like
oh wow but you know me committing to
whatever more more with them whatever
that more is you know it's well or
friendship maybe another maybe another
way to say it is is there something here
you know it seems like I I don't think
you're making a value judgment I think
so I'm asking a clarifying question do
you mean like is there something here
could we be fill in the blank friends
business partners what whatever the
nature of the conversation is in the
context of It kind of it it it the blank
will be filled in different ways but
that's isn't that kind of what you're
saying is like is there something here
is there some sort of chemistry it takes
um
a lot or am I wrong no I'm well this
this is how I understand it it's not
specifically that it's that it takes me
kind of getting to a certain level of
comfort with someone
before I'm like I'm gonna show you the
real Rhett
and it might take meeting you a few
times before I do that and that's not
just a are you worth the investment
sometimes it's that like we talk we've
talked many times about how the like uh
I especially am not like I'm not trying
to be funny most of the time unless I'm
in entertainment mode now most of the
time that means there's a camera
sometimes that means there's a group of
people who I think could benefit from me
being entertaining
um but like
it takes me I have to make a conscious
decision like all right you're going to
go into that mode this mode of like I'm
a guy that will say and do funny things
and but me just my natural disposition
is not that my natural disposition is I
am present and if you ask me a question
I will answer it I'll I'll talk to you
about anything I'll talk to anyone about
anything I'm not reserved in that way
but I am reserved in terms of like
giving yourself to someone yeah and and
so that means Jesse gets frustrated with
me sometimes because
she's got somebody that she wants me to
meet and she'll have to be like now you
need it like
try with them turn on or like be warm to
them you know and it's not that I'm cold
it's just that when you're not
especially warm you can be perceived as
cold especially when your resting face
is more of a
um
[ __ ] no
no just look at me rest your face and
look at me
um
but but be engaged
like your brow furrows and you're in
deep thought well you seem to be in like
it does seem to be like well oh my gosh
what is this guy I'm gonna throw that
one right back at you because most of
the time no we can talk about me and you
are in a second in a zoom meeting I look
at you and at me and I realize that both
of us are looking at the person like
this furrowed brows I mean especially a
meeting yeah when it comes to a meeting
we're very we're concentrating and we're
thinking I'm like man we're in our brain
I would not want these two guys to be
looking at me like that and I try to
then soften my face a little bit and
then I realized that I just don't
what do you
then I just felt like I'm falling asleep
one of the best things that came out of
the pandemic for me was that I can be in
a meeting and look at myself exclusively
no but seriously I can learn things
about myself like that it's like
if if you've been on Zoom calls for
these past two and a half years and you
haven't learned anything about the
energy you're putting out into the world
yeah you need to you you need to you
need to observe yourself a little bit
now we didn't I didn't change as much as
maybe I thought I should but yeah you
alter your your all to yourself a little
bit it's like oh I need to I need to
turn up the corners of my mouth a little
well if somebody's like I need to be a
supportive active listener like pitching
an idea or especially if they're talking
to us like
do you know there's a there's AI now
that you as you can use as a plug-in on
Zoom that keeps your eyes
uh in contact with the camera no matter
what you do there's a guy on Tick Tock
who demonstrated them and so he and he's
it's actually freaky but it looks
completely normal so he's just like kind
of like what if you look down all the
way
well I don't want you to repeat any
phone I had you on now if I have it on
do not disturb does not mean that Siri
shouldn't disturb me definitely
how come she didn't get the message
she's in the phone I don't have a
relationship with Siri
well I try not to
that was unintentional just break up
with Siri right now
I don't know how you do that
I wasn't
I mean I when I said I was gonna look at
your face I wasn't you know I know you
probably thought I was going to give you
a cheap shot but I I didn't I was I'm
really interested in this I think that
you were that it was just it's the level
of intensity that could be intimidating
I mean when you combine it with height
and like the bigness of the beard and
hair but we can switch to me
for me
I think my first impressions
uh probably just run the gamut because
it's so mood-based for me when I'm
meeting people for the first time I
think it has it's it's so much what vibe
I'm in like
I don't know if I'm
yeah I I'll just exude whatever my
emotions are like and I am being like
and I will take it up a notch like
so it's not just I'm being myself it's
like whatever self I am and kind of in
that that day or that night
I think I that's what I that's the
energy that I try to harness that into
social interaction and sometimes yeah
sometimes I have a funny it comes off
funny anecdote I'm this we were
reselling in a in a setting of really
interesting people uh together
interesting people
um and the guy from West Coast Customs
oh yeah and his entire family were in
this small gathering basically
and I saw you talking to him and the
family
for an extended period of time and uh
and then I was I'm gonna go see what who
Link's talking to so I go over there and
uh Within
20 seconds the wife
of West Coast Customs the guys it was
like
your friend is a
uh
we had developed a rapport yeah I I
could tell she was saying it she was
joking she was being funny but like she
was commenting on your uh she was very
feisty you're you're
um I don't have I haven't yet come up
with a word for it but how would you
describe it uh projecting because she
was
okay yep and I I I really liked her for
it like I mean she was she was dishing
it out as much as she was taking it let
me tell you that and I think she started
it
oh because you think it's foreign if
somebody's giving it to you she entered
the conversation late and so
um
her family introduced her to me is how I
remember it as like oh I we know who
this guy is and she's like I don't know
who you are but that's how the
conversation started so I was like okay
I see where we're going with this I two
can play this game I kind of like this
so yeah that we we were both we were
both doing okay so because that in that
particular instance I was very much in a
in a in a
in a playful in a playful mode whatever
wherever you're going to go with this
I'm going to go with it but if I am if
I'm in kind of a grumpy Zone
yeah I might be a little too sarcastic
with people and um there's lots of times
when I come back from stuff where I I've
met a number of people for the first
time some sort of mixer party type
scenario and I just sit there and just
think about
what what everybody thinks of me and how
and I just I start to feel bad and I'm
like did I get their number so I can
apologize like these things happen hmm
to me a lot or like so I do try to
I'm trying to be more aware of that
um
but for the most I think for the most
part I err on the side of like being
more winsome
but but maybe too extra
and I'm definitely talking like Party
Zone at this point because that's where
you meet people for the first time A lot
of times unless you're putting content
on the internet and people are just
watching you for and then you're
obviously we've done everything that
when we put stuff out there on the show
we're trying to make the best first
impression because we want we want we
want more mythical beasts
I would say that the filter with which
uh we the filter that we apply to what
goes on the Internet is way different
than it was 10 years ago definitely I
mean I was talking to Jessica I'd rather
much more be myself now than win over a
fan who thinks I'm somebody I'm not and
I think that people respond positively I
don't and I'm not talking I took a long
time I'm not talking about that that's
true the vulnerability piece of it but
that's actually not what I'm talking
about okay what I'm talking about is if
you go back 10 years
we curated every single thing that we
put on the internet because we were
putting a lot less on the internet now
with a podcast
with a Daily Show and then an after show
yeah
we're not constantly trying to be
exactly who we think that when we're
being ourselves and as it has been
evidenced many many times
lots of people don't like me or you or
us and that because they've made a
decision that or I don't like this
aspect of them and that's just a part of
putting yourself out on the internet but
then when it comes to
you know uh even pictures uh you know
because sometimes Jesse and I would like
go to an event
and we've got pictures that were then
posting and she and she's like you know
if I'm gonna post pictures that if me
and her in it well she because she has
not put herself out nearly as much as I
have on the internet
and also I think it my particular
opinion is that women have a much harder
time uh uh on the internet than men
because they are constantly objectified
and criticized and put into and you know
their physical appearance is pointed out
much more quickly than it is for a man
so that whole thing for her is like I'm
going to approve like she's going to
look and make sure that the pictures of
her that are going up on my feed are
ones that she approves when she asked me
that question I'm like baby
people have seen me I mean I am a meme
for for a man with and without a beard
like I the worst thing I like I might as
well just have the uh the most
unflattering things you could ever see
from me angles Expressions everything
it's on the internet for everyone to see
you I you never need to approve any
photo of me that goes up and that's
that's changed a little bit a little bit
every single year even stuff you
remember we used to approve every single
photo that would go out officially like
through a mythical thing like this is
going to be on a banner now sometimes
this we still do that like if it's going
to be like the YouTube Banner oh I kind
of want a photo that I kind of think I
look better than not yeah but more often
than not it's just like oh there's
another thing that is going there's
another merch picture I don't I quit
looking at them because I don't like the
way I look 90 of the time so you I just
I just kind of let go of that yeah
um there's nowhere to hide for us so
it's kind of a good thing so I think
that in some ways I've just my
I don't know I think differently about
first impressions in general now because
there's so many different versions that
have gone out there yeah when it comes
to our public persona but back to like
the interpersonal like
am I meeting someone who's going to be a
friend and I'm about to screw it up in
Short Circuit the whole thing I would
just summarize it for me as I don't want
to be misinterpreted as a jerk
and I definitely don't want to actually
be a jerk and both of those things could
happen sometimes not but it's the
minority of this is a really small
minority where I'm actually a jerk and
then there's a good piece of the pie
that's still less I mean I'd say I don't
know what percentage it is
I would hope it's 25 of the time or less
like hopefully less than 20 percent of
the pie is I actually mean well but I
can I'm easily
misinterpreted or easily interpreted
as being a jerk
but then a lot of times it's just like
okay
this dude
this dude is is
a nice guy
for I don't know what a something guy
that's that's my thing I don't want to
be interpreted as a jerk what about you
what are you most concerned about
I think that my philosophy is if this is
someone that I
um want there to be something more like
I like oh this is somebody I would want
to be a friend with
um or this is someone we would want to
work with or whatever I think my
philosophy is
most likely if I just was myself without
trying and also even if I was
understated and didn't say a whole lot
like that person probably has the
wherewithal
to pick up on the things about me that
they like and if I again if I think that
this is something worth pursuing I feel
like there could be a more intentional
second interaction like I actually don't
put a lot of stock in the first
impression I'm not saying that it's not
true but I'm saying that I don't I don't
live my life as if the first impression
is super important because I know that
I'm not good at them and I haven't had
any experience ever where I had a
interaction with somebody that I really
liked and then I didn't I wasn't able to
continue that or further it because of
something I did wrong the first time we
got together okay well that's good just
remember you never get a second chance
to make a second impression either it is
a good slogan second impression let's
get into some voicemails about us but
first let's promote some crap oh it's
it's the start of the year so we have a
dispatchers from Myrtle Beach my dad's
podcast with me this month we're
launching a video version uh so look for
the launch of that YouTube channel if
you want to watch my interaction with my
dad I highly recommend it
um check it out if you haven't it's uh
it's an important part of of my life now
so maybe become an important part of
your life also a hot dog is a sandwich
Josh and Nicole's podcast from the
mythical kitchen is back and it also now
has a video component great format
YouTube channel if you don't know tell
them what the format is they basically
take controversial food opinions and put
them against one another you know the
whole is a hot dog a sandwich that's the
whole
the whole idea there their interactions
are great and they're I mean listen this
is like very consistently one of the top
food podcasts very well respected
within the culinary world because listen
Josh and Nicole are not us they actually
know things about food like significant
things about food like they're very well
informed and just for you to listen to
you won't you not only get hungry but
you'll also learn some stuff about why
about the things you're hungry for and
you'll be hungry for more of their
podcast hot dog is a sandwich
ear biscus is supported by better help
you know what makes me feel good you
mean besides talking to me yes that
makes me feel good but besides that it
makes me feel good to be my best self
man oh you know to give myself the
attention and the work I need to be my
best self you know what I'm getting at
okay yeah well to be my myself I usually
I I unbutton the top two buttons on my
shirt
so today I'm not looking at my best self
why you do that and now I am being my
best self but you know what you can't
always be your best self that is an
impossible task
but working with a therapist could
definitely get you closer to that best
version of yourself and better help is a
great step to get you there you know
we're big fans of therapy and having
access to therapy I mean one of my top
moments
of last year was the growth that I
experienced in therapy
it was a top moment for me as well
my girl you you're a therapy okay yeah
no therapy has been really important uh
for both of us that's why we talk about
it all the time and we think that more
people should have access to therapy and
that's why we're a big fan of Better
Health yeah the cool thing about
betterhelp is that it's entirely online
so you can take that appointment from
anywhere especially if it's your first
time with therapy it'll help ease your
nerves if you're uncomfortable with it
so just fill out a questionnaire so they
can match you with the right person and
if they somehow did not match you with
the licensed therapist of your dreams
you can always switch and it will not
cost you anything extra
if you want to live a more empowered
life therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com ear today to get 10 off
your first month that's better help
h-e-l-p.com slash ear
[Music]
ton link this is Richard I'm calling
from Las Vegas Nevada I'm such a such a
huge huge huge huge fan
Rhett and Link and Good Mythical Morning
and you guys are this uh so freaking
hilarious anyways I'm calling uh I'm
calling about your most recent tweet
that you guys put out you remember the
first time you saw us on the internet
yeah I remember it very very vividly I
was scrolling
through a link aggregator website called
gorilla links
and
it was just a just a thumbnail a view of
YouTube written link sitting in a polar
Ranch
and at this thought it was so unique and
so weird I just I decided to click on it
it went to your YouTube video and from
that day I fell in love with you
you guys this is so so freaking
hilarious keep doing what you're doing
I'm Gonna Keep listening to to ear
biscuits I'm gonna keep watching the
show okay yeah we he okay that got weird
it sounded like he was gonna say
handsome that guy is say when he said
when he said hilarious I just feel like
he was about to you know I feel like he
was gonna say handsome we have we accept
the love you know if you see two guys in
ranch
a tub full of ranch like all the way up
over their faces
that's quite a first impression and for
him that's exactly what he needed to
fall in love because I think some people
would see that and be like I'm not and
I'm not interested in that you know I
mean frankly uh if I saw that I would
not want more
like me personally but did we get any of
those but a lot of people did want more
hi Rhett and Link My name is Donna um I
wanted to share the first time I saw you
guys on the internet
um my boyfriend got a link to one of
your videos it happened to be the will
it Meatloaf uh episode and I he was
watching it I happened to walk in right
as you guys were trying the Taco Bell
meatloaf and I remember thinking it was
the grossest thing I've ever seen I was
like what the heck who the heck are
these guys this is so disgusting I
thought it was so stupid and then
um kind of lo and behold we just
randomly started watching you guys and
since then I think I've watched every
single episode and gone back to catch up
on all the other ones too so
um you know not the best First Reactions
uh you know first impression but
um I do love you guys and now now I get
it now I understand uh in the in the
moment I did it but um but yeah I will
never forget that so hope you guys have
a great day disgusting and stupid those
were that was her first impression yeah
and somehow
we won her over like that hey that feels
pretty good I mean it doesn't get work I
mean those are some pretty pretty bad
terms what I also think is probably the
most common first impression uh we do
less disgusting now but but I'm saying
that stupid it's pretty par for the
course I think if you go back to the
period of time in which we were gaining
uh subscribers at the highest rate we
ever had yeah which is like 14 15. when
the algorithm was changing and all that
and so it was just like rewarding our
content and suggesting it to everybody
um
that was when we were kind of in the
Heyday of hot peppers and gross stuff
yeah and that was when it really worked
it doesn't work nearly as well anymore
and I so I think that if you just do
like a an evaluation of the fan base I
think that this first impression is
probably the most common like if you had
to group it into like they were doing
something stupid yeah disgusting and
stupid
I mean that could have been the name of
the show it could have been the name of
us
yeah which one do you want to be
but we couldn't be contained by those
two terms right
uh let's see this one this didn't hurt
too bad yet
Tyra and Link
um my first impression of you guys was
introduced to me when I was in high
school uh I was in Youth Group at the
time and
um my youth Minister would play your
guys's videos
during our youth group and I remember
the first time he played a video he kind
of advertised it as this is stuff like
we would do at youth group like playing
silly games or eating weird food
so
and it's funny now to know your guys's
journey through deconstruction and also
mine so anyway thanks bye yeah I think
that the uh I don't know how to feel
about this because I'm sure that there's
many a youth pastor out there who has a
lot of regrets
for
introducing uh our content into their
youth curriculum but we put out a lot of
youth group energy I mean that was an
ERA I mean because that because we came
from youth group energy
so yeah even though we never said we
want to make good mythical morning like
a like a youth group with two guys who
uh aren't allowed into youth groups
anymore because of their age and now I
guess because of their beliefs but uh
uh yeah we I I was very self-conscious
about putting out that youth pastor
energy I'm glad she didn't go that far
it's like these guys are just like me
you know well I think we I think we hit
the youth pastor energy pretty hard for
a pretty long time I mean listen talk
about first impressions of like other
YouTubers that we were meeting I bet if
we go back and asking that if they may
not have those words but like when we
started meeting YouTubers they had
everybody like would try to figure us
out and they were like I think it came
down to youth youth pastor energy but
here's here's the thing I gotta say that
now that we're in Los Angeles that if
you were to survey a group of people in
Los Angeles and you were to give them
multiple choice as to what we do for a
living and you gave youth pastor I mean
look at what you've got on look what
I've got I mean especially what you've
got on those glasses and your hair like
and even when I've got on like like if
you're talking like metro area youth
pastor really we're still because
they're yeah we're still because anyone
who looks like they're trying to not
look their age that's the quintessential
sign of a youth pastor if you have if
you come from that world if you do that
in the South you're gonna look a certain
way you know yeah if you do that in Los
Angeles you're gonna look I mean you
obviously I would say this is a cool
look but I'm saying that that but it
looks like somebody who's trying to look
cool and I'm saying I do the same thing
that is that's a that's youth pastor
energy that's like West Coast
that you're telling me I'm just saying
you can't get away from it because
but it's in the behind the it's in the
eye of the boat
it's in the behind of the boulder yeah
I'm not saying you should change
anything or I should I don't know what
they're doing your youth group but I
feel like that is the that's what youth
pastor energy is is someone who is
hanging out with kids a lot and trying
to kind of appeal to them by the way
they dress and the way they do their
hair or whatever I just want to be on
record to say I every fashion Choice I'm
making now is only to appeal to myself
okay
and you you're a youth pastor
[Music]
2012 and the first impression that I
remember having is man these guys should
get new haircuts um and eventually that
did happen so congratulations on
evolution
these guys should get news what year did
she say 2012 yeah
yeah we've had some we've had some some
low points here's a good follow-up I
think all right link it's me Daniel
um
been watching you guys for a while I
just wanted to say I forgot what you
guys asked I'm like
um
what did I think when I saw yours on
that well I first saw you guys when you
started trending like 2015 so back then
I must have been like 12 13. oh the one
thing I remember is at the time I had a
bowl cut and this was before 2016 so
before Lake had cut his hair
so I remember watching them be like man
I think it's just like me
that is so cool he's got a bulkhead just
like me he's awesome it's not a popular
and stuff it wasn't a bulkhead you got
glasses
and that made me feel good about having
glasses
and that was really cool I thought um
barrette
Brett was like
rent was crazy he was like he was like
that guy I wanted to be you know
that guy I was
they were awesome too this dude didn't
even remember the prompt at the
beginning got a haircut
and uh yeah I love both of you guys all
right I'm never going to forget Rhett
was the guy I wanted to be and Link was
the guy that I was
how does he feel now I would like to
know he said he loves us both man all
right let's go to some employees I'm
Really Gonna I'm literally gonna hold on
to that so my dad magic Paisley called
in I we do not know what he said
hey this is Mike Paisley calling from
Cloudy Burbank California
uh and I'm talking about the first time
I met Rhett and Link it was almost 10
years ago and they were two YouTubers
that I'd never heard of but they were a
big ass deal at the time because they
had almost 2 million subscribers and so
when they came to the digital Twigs
studio downtown we're very excited to
meet these these big time YouTubers and
they brought Stevie their producer and
they brought their wives and they
brought their kids and it totally took
out all of the like anxiety of meeting
these like uh these YouTube guys because
they just seem like regular dudes with
kids and it was a really Charming
experience and so
um
I never really liked him though I uh
ever since that day I I wish I hadn't
encountered them JK JK
that's my story about meeting Rhett and
Link for the first time it was great and
uh I'll never forget it
I'll never forget it either yeah because
we knew that they were going to do uh
they were working on the intro for the
medical show which was the stop-motion
animation and we were like this is going
to be super cool it's so cool let's go
back and watch it let's bring all of our
families to the studio this the little
Studio that they have yeah because they
were building it all practically as like
this as like scale models of like a tree
growing out of a volcano under an
underground volcano and like
yeah Paisley was so kind
like to show our kids like how
everything worked and it was awesome it
was awesome and now you know all these
years later he's we got him all to
ourselves
working for us well before you move to
the next one you're moving pretty
quickly my impression of you right now
is that you're moving through these very
quickly and we're not talking about them
just so you know oh okay um
going back to the uh youth pastor thing
uh not what we were talking about but a
very real thing that we've we've talked
about is
the impression that we have and you
might remember the details of this but
like conversations that we have had with
people that we met back in those earlier
days
um where there was a um kind of this
undercurrent
a little bit of tension
you know I talked with Pete Holmes about
this because I went back on the his
podcast to talk about a human overboard
and we were talking about the first time
that we came on the show which was at
the end of 2019 before we told our
deconstruction story publicly in 2020 on
this podcast right and we actually
talked about it on the podcast he was
like yeah there was this sort of
um I can't remember the word that he
used to describe it but when you know
that someone wants to be able to talk
about something but then doesn't that
was a certain energy but I'm actually
saying go back to those early days and
really this was mostly when we were in
North Carolina and then the very early
days in California where
um we were both still identifying as
Christians and even as I was like coming
out of that in like 2012 2013 I still I
was sort of like
coming out of it in an intellectual way
but in terms of just the way my brain
worked and the way I saw the world a lot
of that was still kind of intact and so
we kind of bring
like a suspicion to people of the world
you know what I'm saying and even in
some of those early ear biscuits where
we would interview with somebody
interview somebody and we're asking them
these questions but then not disclosing
uh can you remember any conversations
that we've had in the in subsequent
years about hey how did we come across
did we because I remember somebody
telling us that yeah you guys had some
uh
like holy energy or something I can't
remember how it was described but I
think that was something that
I have since been able to observe and
not just not I'm not going to single out
any anybody of a particular Faith but
anyone who has an agenda and that agenda
is I want you to think like me and I
want you to agree with me and this is
something that everyone including myself
falls into on a pretty regular basis I'm
TR I've gotten much better at it I'm
trying to get better at it
but when you kind of bring that
into a conversation
it's pretty palpable
yeah that can color a first impression
well I mean
being raised in
the Evangelical belief system by
definition is you want to
win people over like you're you're you
believe that Jesus actually
commanded you to do that to
make disciples so to speak well in in to
use the terms so you know and it will be
for this person's benefit and it and
it's and you're not doing it for you
it's like so all of a sudden a first
impression gets wrapped up in like
there's this level of self-awareness
that
okay
I am different in some ways so one of
the most easily easy ways that you can
notice it first are like okay
how clean my language is
or the things that I am not going to do
maybe that's not
drink for some people or maybe it's not
dance for some some religious people you
know so it's there's these certain ways
where you start to you have to be aware
if you want to you want to make a
positive impression because you want to
represent
your relationship with God in a way that
wins people over that entices people
that these are literally things that
Paul talks about in the Bible you know
this is how you need to go about your
life in a way that helps people by
winning them over to the cause of
the faith
so you're aware of these things where
you stick out as different
and
you know you get to you I I think for me
I developed a little bit of a complex on
that front because it's
first impression is not just about are
people going to like me but are people
going to like God that's a lot of
pressure you know and
um
are the things that make me different
it's so hard for it just not to imply
judgment like silent judgment I'm not no
I don't I don't do that it's kind I mean
if somebody is
um has been sober for years and they say
you know what
um I'm sober or I'm in recovery or
whatever terms they use
it's very clear that it's about
this is my process and it kind of short
circuits judgment
you know but I don't do that I don't do
that I don't do that as a just a moral
thing then because you're doing it is
immoral how could it so it's an
implication it was so hard to have that
conversation and it didn't seem like an
effective way in that you just find
yourself hoping that nobody notices and
that's the complex I think that Dynamic
is actually still very present and
probably more present ever in our
culture and I don't think that it is so
we we related to that context from a
Christian standpoint but I think that
our our in America we're so politically
polarized at this point interesting that
um if you're somebody on the left and
you're talking to somebody on the right
and you find out that they're on the
right mm-hmm
it's very difficult for you to not have
immediate judgment in your words and
your face now you're interacting with
them and vice versa vice versa vice
versa yeah I I I don't I don't like to
do the both sides thing I am on one side
of this you know I'm on the left side
but the psychology of it plays both ways
yeah and I think that it it actually is
something that has really
short-circuited what could be uh
fruitful conversations between people I
think is that there is this like okay
because you identify and this is some
this is a new phenomenon like I've been
reading a lot about
just like people people who are really
studying polarization right now because
it is more pronounced than it than it
has been in the recent past I mean sure
maybe way back in the day but like
it's super pronounced right now and
there is and there's there's good reason
I'm not saying that you know oh abandon
your principles but in terms of
immediately categorizing somebody as
okay if you identify in this way then I
can assume all these different things
about you and I actually cannot have a
meaningful dialogue with you and I'm
gonna judge every single thing you say
and I'm going to judge every single
thing you do versus see oh you know what
most likely you are also a human person
who based on your own intuition and your
circumstances and your environment and
your psychological disposition
came to these conclusions that you are
currently at and they may be different
than mine but you're still a human and
we're still All in This Together how do
we have a fruitful conversation
um it's just it's something that you
don't experience very often out here
because we this is a pretty homogeneous
and political environment in Los Angeles
um but it's something that you go back
to the home in North Carolina I was
actually talking to my brother about
this
I was like you know you're you live in a
super purple place you know like you
know and you kind of forget that when
you live in a super red or a super blue
place you kind of forget about those
very very purple places like these
Southern Metro areas uh where on a daily
basis you're going to have meaningful
interactions and you're also going to
have to have meaningful
um meaningful like collaborations with
people from all over the Spectrum like
you have to do meaningful things you
have to get things done you have to have
an interaction with somebody you have to
purchase something from somebody you
have to do a deal with something you
have to work with or to work with yeah
and if you're just going to be like oh
you're on the other end of this spectrum
a spectrum that I believe stands for
everything that is wrong and is
everything that is wrong with our
country and everything that is evil in
our country uh
yeah
you that that energy comes across it
just comes across in your interactions
in the same way that our energy of like
well this is who we are and this is what
we believe about things and because I've
been on both sides of that I'm just you
know I'm trying to be conscious of it in
a way because the point I think is to
have a meaningful dialogue into
arrive at what how are we going to move
forward you know yeah and there I think
there are
a lot of people who like to be put in a
box if it's their box
you know but I I don't I personally
don't like that because I'm not so
firmly
I I you know it's I don't know it just
as an i as a concept of not being taken
as an individual human that has with all
the complexities
is just not it's that's not a place
that's that's not how I want to be
received
um but I think that it's for apparently
for some people they do
yeah on on on whatever extreme right
just what the that's that's what defines
the extreme in my opinion is that like
yeah I this is my box
and I want and I want you to know it I
want it to be the first thing you know
about me if I you know uh that's never
really been
who who who I wanted to be and it's I am
not really interested in that place
because you don't feel like you can you
know no but you're not there's not talk
about active listening you know if the
first thing you say is this is my
identity is my box
like then oh I mean that could sound
very uh interesting my identity is my
ideology my identity is my ideology
it's like well okay do I really want to
keep talking to you if it's like if
that's it if it's that simple
like even if I don't want to change your
mind even if I just want to interact
with you as a person you know it's just
not appealing to me yeah
um but there I do think there's a lot of
people who that's not the case
and who you disagree with about things
and it's that that's
yeah I mean going back to the purple
living in the purple place you know it's
I I think that's something we don't
benefit from you know there's benefits
to it
you know and I I end up saying things
like
you know maybe this is the reason I'm
glad to live where I live because it
just makes it easier but I don't know
there's something good about being
challenged right
well I think I I think it's the nature
of uh it's the nature of a democracy
it's the nature of our country right
there's a hell there's a health to it
and it has functioned
in a generally positive manner for most
of the history of our country and we've
moved from kind of a dark place to a
less dark place like that's the general
uh progression that we have moved and it
has come through the push and pull and
hopefully that's a trajectory of
progressivism and conservatism sort of
like stretching the culture the cultural
blanket across time
um and so right now we're kind of in a
place where the cultural blanket has
been ripped apart and we're just two
people two sides just standing there
kind of looking at each other holding
one half of the country
right and it's just like well how do we
get this thing back together and keep
moving it because we have been moving
towards equality for more people that is
the general disposition of humanity and
culture over time and that's the that's
why I'm on the Progressive side because
that's the I want to keep pulling the
blanket but I don't want to pull it so
hard that it comes that it tears or it
comes out of the conservative's hands
because at that point we'd have no
longer of a functional democracy it's
not easy to do
but I think that the moment we just rip
it away and we're like we're not even
the same people anymore
well yeah but we're still both citizens
of the same country and you have this
your vote has the same power that my
vote has and what does it do me more
good to sit there and make fun of you
and call you an idiot or does it make
more does it or me to have a
constructive dialogue with you if I
think that I've got the the right point
on this don't I want to maintain some
kind of connection so I can have a
conversation I'm not saying to
compromise your beliefs I'm just saying
how do you still how do you maintain a
conversation
and you can and you can it's true to say
it the other way too
can you sit there and call me an idiot
and then and and then expect me to
actually listen to anything you have to
say right right yeah it goes both ways
yeah
okay
um you want to keep going I think we've
officially pissed off as many people as
we possibly could how did that piss off
anybody because anytime I just feel like
we didn't we didn't take a stand on
anything exactly exactly except except
that people should work together but
that pisses off people on both sides
that's the problem okay so now we're
pissing off everybody both extremes okay
I'm fine with that but we are a country
with extremes that's where we are right
now that's all I'm saying so by trying
to say is there some way that we can
work together and move things forward
you're going to piss both sides off I'm
just saying that's the state that we're
in right now I wish I could quote of
course you know who am I going to quote
right now if I could but I can't Bono
when he was on brene Brown's podcast
um uh back in December it
I mean he talks he I mean in like a
little one little question he talks
about this
um and he kind of has this he has his
own Theory
about centrism it's interesting I'm I'm
not gonna I can't quote it but it's like
it there's a reflection of that in this
so like hey I feel like
I feel like there's some there's some
people that I can Harbor with
Bono this good guy I think I gotta to
put a little Safe Harbor
[Music]
um
I I want to go to another kg called in
now kg is relative
um well she's not a relative she's a
mythical crew member she's a she's a she
she's worked with this relatively short
amount of time less than a year I
believe yeah
so I let me let's see what she said
hey yo it's your girl kg
um and my first impression came from
when I started watching you guys in
college I used to watch you guys all
four years every morning
um right before I got ready for class
and the first impression I got off was
these goofy silly curious guys
um that gave off the comforting dad
Vibes and that's why I would usually
watch you guys because the positive vibe
you gave off the videos was just
amazing and it really helps me through
all four years of college and when I
first met y'all it was my second day at
work and I was in the zone doing my
start paperwork and I could see from the
corner of my eye on the bullpen that two
figures just like stopped and I looked
up and it's written link and I
internally I'm freaking out and Link's
like oh you're the new PA because they
just sent out an email welcomed me into
the company the day before I was like
yeah it's me my name is Carolina and
other people call me kg and it was funny
seeing them attempt to say my name but I
was like no it's good like you can call
me just call me kid sometimes people
call me Kevin Garnett just to make a
joke thought it was funny then we
started talking about basketball
and then they welcomed me I was like so
excited to see your work and like happy
that you're here and it was just very
welcoming so the impression I got while
watching their videos really really like
met with the in-person Impressions which
is just insane because I looked up to
you guys in college and
and it's it's just crazy to work with
you all so yeah I think the impression
from watching you guys really met up to
in person
thanks kg too nice Jenna come on you you
gotta you gotta give us some dirt
because I mean like Paisley Paisley
Paisley was nice kg was nice no but no
other employees no one called in I can't
believe no one else called in uh okay
people are afraid yeah
I'll I'll
share the dirt we because we met uh
I had at a bar we met at a bar yeah I
had submitted an application to work as
your personal assistant and we had set
up uh a meeting in like a week a week
later or so yeah but your interview yeah
my interview but then Laura my best
friend she was doing makeup on the show
invited me as her plus one to your end
of year holiday party
and I was like okay they're gonna be
there in my head I'm just like I swear
if they make me do some sort of
interview at this party is going to be a
no it's gonna be absolutely immediate no
for me and so I show up I know to take
the job okay just keep yeah I'm sorry
yeah okay
I was like I'm like I'm just going to go
to a party I'm going to a party We're
not gonna talk about how that I'm
interviewing with them in a week we're
just I'm just going to a part so I show
up and then you two are like one of the
first two people that I see there and so
I introduced myself and I was like hi
I'm Jenna and immediately link is like
hey we should do the interview now yeah
I'm about to say you think that he's not
going to do that and I go
absolutely not
I I immediately was like absolutely not
this is your party you should have fun I
know I'm gonna have fun let's do our
interview another time at the regularly
scheduled time and that was the end of
it and that was the end of it and I was
like okay great they didn't mind me
saying no and they didn't mind uh and
they understand work-life balance I was
like this is good this is a good first
step I pushed back and they were like
you're right cool and I was like all
right okay I could probably work for
these guys but then my whole thing at
the party was getting to know Jesse and
Christy I was like I was because good
strategy that always helps well for me I
just in the past assistant jobs that I
had that some some were quite intense
and it was very much there was no
work-life balance and
um some old bosses Partners were less
than kind to me and I didn't mean to
laugh
they were less than kind so I was like I
was like okay if their wife's gonna be
there I'm gonna get to know Jesse and
Chrissy if we get along I'm gonna give
this a shot I'm gonna give this a shot
with these guys because I like I wasn't
really applying to we're really looking
to say no at every turn I was yeah I was
yeah you didn't want to get wrapped up
in another bad situation yeah I didn't
want to get it wrapped up I I wasn't
looking to uh be an assistant again
because I didn't want to get in another
bad situation but I was like I don't
know these guys sound cool I never heard
of you before the um Laura showed me
your sodang dark video and I was like oh
that's fun that's creative that's uh
interesting like I like I like that
style uh it's my favorite song of yours
now honestly but um but when I said and
that was the end of it I was actually
being facetious because I I swear I
remember interviewing you at the party
no like I remember sitting next to you
you sat down with me and I was like
don't talk about this and and then we
started talking a little bit and I was
like you had a conversation but yeah it
was a conversation it wasn't like a
hardcore interview okay so we had a we
had a little power Dynamic if I remember
it correctly if you thought it was a
power Dynamic it wasn't for me I thought
we were just chilling I kept making you
say no to the interview yeah which was
the interview so in my mind I
interviewed you in your mind you you
stood up to be an interview I was like
so we both won well so I remember
correctly no I know that I knew that
there's no you're not gonna keep him
from doing something like that so I knew
that was going to happen I knew I would
not do that and I knew that you um
would likely
resist it but also I knew that our
interviews especially for a an assistant
role or very much just like do we like
you yeah do we get along with you
exactly would We Vibe with you socially
so I knew that just hanging out with you
was
a big part of the interview but it
wasn't an interview so it wasn't going
to be which is really wasn't going to
feel any different than hanging out with
somebody yeah which is why I literally
thought to this day that we did have the
interview like because I made I made I
made my decision for me it wasn't an
interview for me I was just like I told
them we're not gonna do a big interview
we'll just talk and hang out and have a
good time have a party we're at a party
everybody's drinking I was like I was
like a cocktail or two in it's like you
want to ask me questions about my life
sure
right because you might do that anyway
man who played who here I'm pretty sure
I don't know I think we both played each
other
it works it works but yeah I ended up
talking with Jesse and Christy the most
out of everyone and just like I mean
adored them I was like all right all
right if these women are married to
these men all right I can I can all
right I'll give this interview a shot I
use definitely I use Jesse as a as my
like secret weapon for First Impressions
most of the time because I'm just like
it's if we're going someplace as a
couple
I know that she's going to be outgoing
in a in in like very very warm and
people are going to connect with her and
then I'm like okay she
she cut in fact it's actually made me be
able to sort of just like retreat a
little bit which may not be a positive
thing because I'm like I know that she's
going to be super sweet and super nice
to these people and like start a
conversation she's gonna start
disclosing something she probably should
disclose the first time that she meets
somebody because she's an oversharer but
people feel trusted and connected with
and then and then she can kind of tell
me
well yeah I really like this person and
then okay well next time I'll also talk
to them
we're just similar her and I are very
similar because I I have a tendency if
in the right circumstances if someone
asks a personal question I'll over share
if they ask I'm gonna just share I'm
like all right well you don't even have
to ask Jesse yeah she'll just say it but
another thing about that over sharing if
you if you're comfortable sharing it
though
unless other people are uncomfortable
hearing it oh is that a component
can I give you a little insight into
links very interesting life I've had a
lot of crazy things happen and sometimes
when I say things people are very
uncomfortable because they're like oh
huh I I do I feel like and
well okay
I I get that I I think my mentality is
I'd rather put a little bit more of
myself out there even if it's like
people are like reeling a little bit
because it is part of who I am and if
that's not if if you're going to have a
negative reaction to that then there's
nothing here for us
and now you know that so you know I
guess another way to say it is like
you know if just be yourself and if
people
first impression is negative and you're
being yourself then
everybody's one because you you can both
move on and you're not you know you're
not uh
it's not manipulative
you know so it's in the moment I think I
do err on the side of risking making
somebody feel a little uncomfortable
oh hopefully with my it as long as this
with
something that's that's true of me then
I'm giving them information where they
can run for the hills kind of a thing
so maybe I'm being defensive here but I
honestly I think that that's part of
what's behind it is like
you know this might be a 10 minute
conversation and you might be like is
that guy always like that or is this you
know
and then you might say like is that guy
always like that because I like that guy
or is that guy always like that because
I'm never talking to him again mission
accomplished
but if people get the wrong impression
of you yes it does then I don't want
that right right so yeah so people get
confused and don't know because I agree
with your mentality in general and I
think you should always be yourself but
if you're if you
like oh I said something to that person
that's offensive and actually didn't
mean to offend them and now I've got
something that I need to
that I mean that's the only thing if
people are going to be offended by me in
our first interaction let's not have a
second one
I I do care I don't want to offend
people but if there's certain things
that like if you take yourself too
seriously it's not gonna work for us
honestly you know I mean and I don't
want to hurt people's feelings
but that's how I feel about it I mean
it's like wow Jenna she's really an open
book but something she shared made me
uncomfortable
uh do you regret sharing it if that's
information that like you were
comfortable sharing that then it's like
as long as it didn't trigger them
I think for me it's one of those people
that's just like it's a realization of
because I've some of my stories are
unusual for a lot of people so then it's
like seeing their reaction and be like
oh uh right right I am not normal cool
should I and then it becomes this
thought of
like does that person deserve to know
this thing about me
yes that I but again that's a you thing
not a them thing yeah right
to me that's where I draw the line I
mean there's like a couple of different
lines that I'm trying to draw but like I
I'm I I like talking about this because
yeah I'm dialing it in
I'm dialing it in you know well it
worked so you got you got me that's why
it worked it worked in this instant
another thing about that party I will
say that kind of uh sold me a bit was
um
the
bonsai tree uh trimmer who was there at
the party who was uh trimming a giant
bonsai tree the whole the whole party
yeah and I had this I was like that is
something I've never seen I seriously
had like a 30 minute conversation with
that man yeah I was very fascinated and
I was like these guys that was our idea
this was our insistence yeah I was like
these guys brought this to a party
that's interesting okay yeah yeah just
yeah just so people who wanted to talk
to him could talk to him he hasn't been
back since though nope
that's we would love her and it's our
fault
let's see what this one holds
so my first video I watched of Rhett and
Link uh good mythical morning was eight
weird ways to open a bottle and my first
Spotlight
grown men having sex
oh orange soda
I thought it was so strange and I
decided to not watch any of their videos
for like a month because I I was so
confused uh but I ended up watching more
videos
um and here I am eight years later so
shout out to eight weird ways to open a
bottle and that very very strange time I
had
so we were having too much fun we scared
her away we were too old to have too
much as much fun as we were having
and you know what we gave her the
information and it took her a month she
let it settle to figure out that she
needed that in her life the next time
she had orange soda and she was like
look think about all the ways I could
open this with my eye socket
I you I think that actually using your
eye socket was not one of them but it
was the thumbnail
yeah that was a kind of a deceptive
thought yep yep we don't do that often
the first thing I remember about seeing
Rhett and Link on the internet was
actually when I was
13 or 14 I saw the thumbnail for the
season three Good Mythical Morning
episode titled the most amazing optical
illusions on the internet and at the
time uh seeing the thumbnail I uh it
looked fishy to me and I in my head
thought it was something potentially
sexually explicit so I did not click on
it uh but that thumbnail kept popping up
in my feed
and one day I you know being a horny
teenager I was like all right I'm gonna
click on and watch whatever this is and
I click on it and it it was nothing very
explicit it was two dudes of the
internet looking at
uh optical illusions but uh that's
kickstarted seven eight years ago of
being a fan
um let what you all do but yep that's
how I got interested
wow talk about being disappointed like
he had to work up the nerve and then
well the drive to click on the video
you're looking at the thumbnail right
now I'm trying to make sure that this
that's definitely it's gonna be it that
was definitely it it's got this so it's
from eight it's from nine years ago it's
the uh well I started playing now how
many views does that have about 22
million good gosh so it's a picture of
an optical illusion it's just like a
photograph of two people hugging and the
one person like has a a halter top on
but you only see the person's back so
it's like the shoulders are exposed so
there is a lot of skin and then but like
the placement of the head looks really
weird because it's the other person's
head it's the other person's head I mean
I remember what it was like to be a
horny teen and it doesn't I mean there's
there's a more than enough skin shown in
this thumbnail even though it's just
back skin upper back skin of a woman
it doesn't take much
um that is hilarious but it's funny
because I wouldn't have thought that it
was sexually explicit but I would have
clicked on it because there was so much
skin right right
maybe we should put more skin in our
thumbnails
all the skin on our face we didn't have
so much face skin
hi Rhett hi link
um the first Good Mythical Morning
episode I saw was the outrageous camping
gear you must own episode from eight
years ago at the time I was probably
nine years old
and
I remember watching it and thinking wow
this is really boring I don't think I'm
gonna continue watching this
but then
a while later when the willit episodes
came out that just piqued my interest
and I've been a fan ever since so thank
you guys for such amazing content
well somebody gave us a second chance
you never get a second chance to bore
somebody out of their minds when they're
nine years old you know what being nine
that was the problem honestly
I think what kind of camping are you
doing you know I just don't have a
budget for camping I feel like it's like
a story this story reinforces my theory
um which I think is maybe the uh a
mirror to your theory Germans love David
Hasselhoff so if your theory is you're
going to give people potentially too
much and if too much
is too much for them
then you don't need anything with them
I go in thinking I'm gonna give you too
little
and if too little of me the little bit
of me that I do give you if you don't
like the little bit of me that I give
you then you're not going to like the
more of me that I give you so therefore
the next time we meet I might give you a
little bit more and that's my
prerogative
and again I think that's just a
personality disposition I'm not saying
one is right and one is wrong I just
don't tend to be extra in general it's
just not my disposition so
if I'm not going to be and then I'll
simmer down and if I'm going to be a
little bit not enough right because I do
worry about that sometimes I'm like
ah did I just did I come across as like
boring or uninteresting because I like
I'm in this town of really interesting
people and if I just seem like some you
know tall guy with Jesus hair who stands
in the corner and doesn't talk to
anybody like you know I don't I don't
want to be that guy necessarily
um but in this case I can't remember her
name now uh when she was nine she
watched the video she thought we were
boring but there was something there was
something that she saw
that she was willing to come back later
will it and then be like okay I'm gonna
give these guys another chance I think I
just I'm food I think I'm just believing
in the second that you never get a
second chance you you know what you
might get a second chance to make a
second impression that's my philosophy
no you would get a first chance to make
a second impression that's what I've
been trying to tell you
you never get a second chance to make
any number of impression
it's you only get one chance with every
number it is a yeah you might get a
first chance to make a second impression
but I might call that the next chance
you might get another chance to make
another impression
yep that's my fault there's always
another chance to make another
impression
that sells in blue right there there's
always another chance if that if that
didn't work for you
Try Us
yeah
there you go and also I think that's
consistent with our uh mentality of
putting so much content on the internet
if you didn't like us here forget it you
can see if you can like it you cannot
avoid us if you have an internet
connection we've made that very clear
right right right
that's good and boy if you don't like us
which again stand in line there's a lot
of people
we give you ample reason over and over
again every single day it's like those
guys are now doing this man maybe I'm
the one who's wrong
hahaha
you're not saturation you're not we're
over saturated we're not for everybody
but we're for you you know what we are
for you yeah if you've made it this far
in this podcast yeah we probably are for
you yep so thank you for sticking around
uh we're gonna keep doing this again
this year again every single week
there's gonna be another ear biscuit
just like this one you can count on it
hashtag ear biscuits uh to give us your
written feedback and if you want to call
in and just let us know how you're
processing all this please do one eight
eight eight
earpod one and I have a little wreck yes
you do uh I've talked about this in a
recent podcast so I'm not going to go
into detail but I'm gonna it wasn't my
official wreck and now it is uh very
very famous book Man's Search for
meaning from Victor Frankel
it's like four and a half hours if you
want to listen to it so I don't know how
many hours that is if you want to
actually read it but it's a small time
commitment and a big reward for hearing
about mostly his experiences uh you know
through the uh
concentration camp concentration camps
during the holoca Holocaust yeah so it's
you know puts things in perspective
Man's Search for meaning
all right talk at you next week love you
hi my name is Cadence and my uncle
absolutely loves you guys and he's
actually a straight sweeper and when he
heard link talking about how he's
jealous of street sweepers he actually
cried happy tears because it
he never felt like he was really that
important and it was just it was a nice
thing for him anyway I hope you all have
a good day bye
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
foreign
[Music]